breaking overnight federal health
officials are casting doubt on the
results of a new astrazeneca study that
we told you about yesterday and our dr
david against joins us now
david good morning to you this is highly
concerning yesterday
it sounded like the vaccine was headed
for approval and then i should say the
word concerning comes up
in this overnight statement from a
review board what can you tell us
it's concerning to me too and so the
data safety monitoring board is a board
that's set up
independent of the pharmaceutical
company to look at the data in the trial
and to make sure that everything is
correct and that there aren't
major side effects and that the efficacy
is ported as appropriate
well last night they reported that
astrazeneca had put out data from march
11th when there was data going all the
way to march 16th and there are 141
events
reported in the clinical trial and
apparently there were more cases of cova
that were possible or probable
over those next several days which would
have brought down the efficacy number
by almost 10 percent and so this
certainly brings you know question into
the data reporting
into what's going on here and you know
when i look at this
this is the dominant vaccine in the
world and we've just
questioned the data around it again well
so that's an important point dr
agus this is being used widely outside
of the united states we already have
three vaccines here within the u.s so
what does this mean for the global
supply
it's certainly scary and that countries
like you know europa put it on hold
for a potential blood clot issue that
turned out not to be the case we are
told
um and you know we need this vaccine to
get out of cova globally in europe and
africa especially
yeah we need it to get out of covett
globally that's the key point dr david
agus thank you very much we will see you
again in our next hour to talk about
another part of this pandemic
life after vaccination for those who've
been lucky enough to receive their shots
thank you very much